upcoming episode of your show crashing
is called BARC Oh actually it's I know
if it's called BARC but it features you
bark doosron called barking yeah which
is a term many people may not be
familiar with but it's something
comedians have to do to drum up business
to come see their show comedians and the
and the carny folk yeah and the carny
folk are any folk you know barking is
when they like hey I'll guess your
weight you know yeah yeah that one's
done that in 200 years I feel like you
you'd be you'd be good at it you're good
I'd be a good Barker I would I'd like to
see you in one of those very light foam
hats and a pencil-thin came I think I
should do it for this show out on in
front of Warner Brothers I think are you
concerned buzz feets running out a list
[Laughter]
but you know we had to bark barking
handing out flyers in exchange for sage
time maybe you've been to Manhattan and
you see these these kind of huddled
comedians handing out flyers trying to
get people interested yeah that's what I
used to do for stage time and that's
something crashing is kind of about what
it's like to start as a stand-up so
we're telling these stories about that
people may not know and the fun thing is
we actually shot it on MacDougal and
third in the West Village which is where
I really barked that's when you were
starting out that's where you barked
every every night for many months in the
winter was terrible I was listening to I
don't know 311 and and then so we got to
shoot there and it was super fun but you
know we're shooting at like 4:00 a.m. in
the West Village so occasionally I don't
know if you've been to Manhattan but a
few freaky geek ease will come up to you
yeah some oddballs yeah and there was
this one kind of local insane person was
fond of I would see her every day
and she came up to me finally to say
hello and you're on the street there's a
whole camera crew lights everything
exactly I'm feeling like oh this is my
moment right and she comes up and she
goes hey are you the movie star and I'm
like you know it's it's not a movie
I'll give her a thrill um I guess ma'am
I am indeed the movie star and then she
you know [ __ ] her arm back and grabs my
nuts what like she formed the Talon this
is a true story form the Talon rammed it
into my nuts I'm an actor at this point
so I'm so used to people you know
prodding and yeah yeah I don't even move
I'm just like blah I'm afraid that if I
resist it's like a bear trap so it'll
only get worse
yeah tear loose yeah everything up and I
want to keep it yeah and then the
director Jeff Shafer a great Curb Your
Enthusiasm director we were working but
he comes over seeing she's still holding
them I felt the warmth of her hand and
and he comes over and I'm about to be
like Oh Jeff don't worry it's okay you
know don't don't yell at this poor woman
and he gives her $20 and everyone
applauded everyone applied I was like
this is how you treat the goddamn Big
Cheese
has anyone ever used the the comedies
had no respect cuz I would work here I
don't think so I don't think anyone's
ever used it it's yours if you want it
no respect
you